so
so what do you say to the folks where
like you know what you're saying right
now
i had a lot of people here that read
your book because it's uh
it's fascinating what you're writing
about and it kind of i believe there's a
lot of it going on today and you got a
lot of people speculating saying
this economic hitman job china's
mastering
and what do you say to those that they
had
a president like trump who's the most
difficult person the
person china's dealt with keeps putting
tariffs on top of tariffs on top of
tariffs on top of tariffs
and china did the ultimate economic hit
job which is the world economic hit job
by releasing a virus that got into all
these other countries and
trillions of dollars was lost around the
world based on a virus like that
do you think there is any chance any
chance
that a part of that virus had to do with
an economic hitman's
job philosophy that you have to say you
don't want to negotiate with us your
strong arm in me
watch what what i'm going to do to you
do you think any chance of that could
take place
with what happened recently with
coronavirus my personal opinion no
why is that because
china suffered from it too i think the
united states
made huge mistakes if china wanted to to
show us as a country that's really
failed and taking care of its people it
certainly succeeded in that you know a
country with
less than five percent of the world's
population has about 25 of the
coronavirus deaths that's that's
unacceptable that's ridiculous the
largest economy in the history of the
world and we can't take care of our
people
so the virus certainly showed our
weaknesses up so if china had wanted to
do that they've certainly succeeded
but it's really difficult for me to
believe that
that anybody would create a virus like
that and have it hit their own country
and and spread around the world
anything's possible i know that from
from from my own experiences
there's always stories behind the story
so there's always that possibility i
would never say
never but in my opinion i think that's
extremely unlikely i think that you know
people like like bill gates had had had
prophesized and
projected that there would be a virus
about five or six years ago he said this
is likely to happen many medical
authorities have said
that it was bound to happen at some
point we were poorly prepared for it
and i in my opinion we've uh our
national government has
has made a terrible job of dealing with
the situation
got it you know i mean if if you're
saying the fact that you know
uh a country with five percent of the
war population has 25 percent of death
that means china doesn't have that many
deaths which means it kind of worked out
for them
right if if it was because it didn't
really hurt them as much as
you're saying it hurt america it
destroyed america if it's like a
quarter of all the death that took place
based on the data that you're saying
so that means it could be possible that
they did do it and it was victorious for
them no
yeah thailand's done really well too
they've had even fewer deaths because
they've got such a good health care
system
so it's possible that thailand created
the the virus and planted it in a
chinese factory
the fact of the matter is you could say
that about almost every country because
the one that's done most poorly is the
united states so i think no i'm only
saying it to you because you
are the guy that wrote the book economic
hit shock which is
which which gets us who live in america
to sit there and say
if america did it to so many people
maybe china's now retaliating and doing
it the ultimate way i don't know i'm not
the one that's speculating
wait a minute wait a minute we we never
created a virus we never did anything i
never said virus i never said
like that i mean it's friendly warfare i
never said bio warfare
i just said the model of an economic
because everybody when you read the
you know business model of china the
u.s you make a very good point when you
say 54 we're investing into buying ships
and buying this and buying that what for
how much of that was really taking place
today why don't we spend some of that
money into
protecting ourselves in a different
military way cyber security all this
others a very very accurate statement
you're making absolutely
the right people i'm hoping listen to
this and realize maybe we need to
go in the direction what you're talking
about you know the next war is not gonna
be the war that we're accustomed to
seeing from the 70s and 80s and
world war ii or world war one we're
seeing the bio warfare
can destroy economies and shut down an
entire nation
and the one country that's always
bragged about being the best and that is
in america it's always been china
so that's why a part of this speculation
when you come in
and in the middle of the interview my
brain just went wait a minute if that's
what if there you know it could be
possibility i don't know people have
brought it up to me let me just ask john
since he's the expert here so and and
the other part is you know
the complete opposite argument of the
five percent of world's population
u.s 300 million of 7.5 billion yet
25 of the death that's also assuming
john that the data china has given the
world is accurate no
true true it does assume that
you're right it's tough to trust a
nation that doesn't have free press
it is you're right no that's i don't
trust china i'm not saying that i
that i trust china but i am i think what
if you look historically countries that
wage
war and other countries usually want to
have pretty good control over their
weapons it's one of the reasons
that countries fear nuclear weapons
because we fear that we don't really
have that much control once you set off
the nuclear reaction
who knows where that's going to go so
that you know based on history
it it's hard for me to believe that you
release a virus
around the world and you don't have much
control over you don't know who it's
going to hit
and so to me you know i'm not saying
that biological warfare
can't happen or isn't happening possibly
it is but
if it is we're in
we're in really really deep trouble uh
and
does it does that mean we should
retaliate with our own biological
weapons no not at all zero what does it
mean
no not at all i don't think that let's
say let's say that we we actually
we actually proved that china did do
this what would be our response
i'd be curious to know what you say to
because i have my own ideas what would
you do to it
if if it's proven that this did happen
and you know the
we take him to the tribunal and we put
him on court everybody does the
investigation everything happens yep
they started it they released it they
knew what's happening and
it caused shambles around the
around the world what do you think needs
to happen to china
that anybody could do i can't possibly
imagine
i really can't patrick what do you think
i got to tell you i'm learning how you
sat down with these prime ministers and
presidents and but i hope all the
audience has taken notes
have you noticed how phenomenal he is
you